what's going on guys this is rob and i
just woke up a little bit ago and i'm
using my voice i'm making it an octave
or two higher because you wouldn't be
able to handle my voice as it exists
right now it'd be very deep so
most all of you would just
fall apart
you can't handle it
so having said that
we need to talk about thor 4 because
there are things we need to talk about
from this movie because
i still don't care about about gore's
head tails and and nose that still
doesn't matter to me what matters to me
is all the stuff that does matter which
is how they handled the character
which was kind of okay so uh let's get
into the easter eggs right let's get
into the little easter eggs references
all the stuff you missed there's a lot
of stuff you missed and in fact we'll
address one of the great big huge things
a lot of fans are pissed off about right
now i wouldn't even say pissed off about
that a lot of fans are just kind of like
okay this is getting a little out of
hand right well we will address that as
we get closer to the end of the video
because it's kind of a big deal right so
first things first right gore that's the
guy we got to talk about that we get
this depiction of gore basically
carrying his child on a desolate planet
which of course is in reference to the
comics those guys don't know the deal
about that literally thor lived on a
world where it was just harsh and
desolate and really really crappy pretty
much exactly what you saw in the movie
and he essentially lost his family over
time due to the desolate nature of that
world imagine living in the sahara
desert and that's like your whole planet
right tatooine from star wars and so
because of that like losing everything
and the fact that god's never answered
their prayers in the comics gore started
taking revenge of the gods because once
he realized they existed he realized
they suddenly just didn't care and so
that's one of the cool things that we
saw is that in this movie right the
black armor guy
basically bears this incredibly striking
resemblance to null the symbiote god but
it's kind of insane right the idea of
null
being or at least existing and this is
kind of confirming it but not really
because we don't know exactly what
direction they're going to go in right
in the comics right now
that was null the symbiote god that fell
in that battle with the the army of
golden gods and then basically ended up
you know having his necro sword picked
up by uh by gore right that's how that
was in the comics when gore originally
appeared in the comics that was not the
case because null had not been created
yet he didn't exist quote unquote in
terms of like donnie kate's creating his
character and all that kind of stuff it
hadn't happened yet right so it's one of
those things where they could go either
way the fact that is in effect the story
of null to a degree and even the
celestials in omnipotent city which
we'll talk about here in a minute
because all there's a ton of evidence in
this movie that points to the idea that
it had that it that that is in fact null
the symbiote god this looks like that
may very well be the direction they're
going in and if it is and if it is no
the symbiote god
man it's going to be insane because null
man there's there's a point there's
there's a there is a point in the story
right the king in black which we covered
over comics explain there's a point
where null [ __ ] like when he finally
shows up to earth
nobody on earth ever had a chance like
none of the superheroes ever had a
chance like it was it was it was
absolutely crazy we'll talk about that
later right we gotta we gotta stay on
track i'm doing my best to stay on track
we gotta we gotta do that right so the
power's the necro sword right that they
it's basically the ability to summon
like the shadow beasts and so on that
are that are very very alien in terms of
how they look and again this is likely a
reference to the fact that null is the
god of the symbiotes because they look
kind of alien but they also look very
symbioty right is that a word symbiotic
symbiotic
they they look like symbiotes in a lot
of ways right that's the cool thing here
is because what we get is is this idea
that no the symbiote god really does
have a hand here because those shadow
monsters that's the living abyss again
like we'll talk more about that because
i feel like there's this huge moment
right the shadow realm and all that kind
of stuff right that whole thing where
it's like that's where the sword comes
from but the thing about this is we
switch over right you get like this
whole this whole like stage play now
this is likely just a call back to
ragnarok i don't know why it wouldn't be
right thor's a nod to like dr blake dr
donald blake right he literally uses his
umbrella slams it on the ground then
they do like the transformations like
you know what i mean that's a reference
to like the old thor comics those of you
guys who don't know back in the day when
when thor first came into existence what
you had or at least was first introduced
to us as the reader what you had was
donald blake who was by all standards
the measurement of coward and there's
like literally an alien invasion in just
this little small segment of the world
where he's hanging out with jane foster
and he just runs away because he's a
coward and he ends up in a cave where
he's trapped in this cave and there's
just like a stick that's literally just
sitting on this rock and he gets
frustrated and he hits the stick on the
ground or maybe he hits on the cave wall
i can't remember it's one of those two
and it turns into mjolnir and it turns
him into thor and that's the way that
worked for years in marvel comics right
the superhero alter ego identity that
was still widely popular in the 60s
stopped being popular in the mid 70s was
totally gone by the time he got into the
80s and that was basically it but for
years in marvel comics donald blake
would hit his walking stick on the
ground and he would turn into thor right
and the stick would turn into mjolnir so
this was a really really cool reference
i absolutely love that especially like
as an old-school comic book fan infinity
cones let's talk about infinity cones
the ice cream shop let's be honest guys
we would all go there every single one
of us would go there and in fact like i
remember sitting in the theater and
people were just like like there were
people who were commenting like i wish
that place existed i do i know you do
like we all kind of do and we would go
there right like like infinity cones an
infinity gauntlet themed ice cream
restaurant right just named after thanos
i thought it was a great little funny
moment and that kind of a thing of
course we also get the return of the old
cast right dr selvig and darcy and jane
and lady stiff and all that it is cool
to see that and i'm going to be honest
with you guys you know even now i get
that thor is going more in the direction
of like the comedic story which is fine
right i don't necessarily have a problem
with comedic thor i think it's kind of
wearing out its welcome to be honest
like i i kind of i kind of miss like the
old school sirius thor i do like that
they address all the reasons why thor is
just so comedic now right as opposed to
being like you know hyper serious and
that kind of a thing in fact there's a
great juxtaposition that takes place
between zeus and thor that we'll talk
about later but one of the big things is
i i do kind of miss that that's sort of
nostalgia right that old school thor
movie now a lot of that i think is is
really less about the serious nature of
thor and more about just like the first
10 years we were being introduced to all
these characters for the first time but
i do kind of miss that to a degree uh so
it was cool to see everybody i was like
the gang's back together again you know
what i mean like it was a nice bit of
nostalgia that we got over the course of
the film now of course we also get the
line by odin's raven that of course was
a line said by will ferrell in anchorman
there was also by the beard of zeus
which was kind of crazy jane of course
has stage four cancer which is a direct
comic reference but it's actually also
bigger than that it's a main focal point
of her character we also did a video
over a comics explained called jane
foster explained which if you're
interested will basically make you an
expert on the character but the big
caveat is that when jane foster was made
thor in marvel comics jason aaron quite
literally put the kibosh on it right
this idea that people were like well
she's gonna be around forever she's
gonna replace you know
thor odin's son forever and ever and
ever now he put the kibasha on that fast
and was like no no no she's not going to
be thor forever we're not replacing thor
odin's son and if you really believe
that's the case you don't know anything
about comics which is a true statement
so the thing about that is when she had
cancer the way it worked is she would
undergo chemotherapy but every time
every time she turned into thor it would
wipe the chemotherapy out of her system
so she would always be reset but her
cancer would continue to progress so it
was basically jason aaron's way of
saying she's gonna die and she did in
the comics she basically died and then
became valkyrie is really how that
worked now the cool thing here is of
course you also get thor's helmet and
his general outfit it's really a
reference to his thor comic book outfit
which actually debuted in thor number
378 back in the day so that's a cool
little thing omnipotent city's visited
where we basically get like all the gods
that are part of marvel's sky fathers
which i loved i thought it was a great
thing and i've been wondering for a long
time what are we going to get sky
fathers in hindsight i think it makes
more sense that they introduce them with
omnipotent city than without omnipotent
city and the reason why is because if
you look at the nature of the sky
fathers in marvel comics when you got
jason aaron's run on thor which this
this whole movie was basically jason
aaron's run on thor just different
aspects of it used in different ways or
sometimes reworked but the thing about
this is that he introduced omnipotent
city as a place where quite literally
all the gods can meet right so you got
like the like like the huge omnipotence
library and all that kind of stuff where
it's like every god who's ever existed
and everything they've ever done like
all that cool stuff right now the thing
here is that when the sky fathers were
basically rolled over into that what it
did is it created cohesion and they
created organization to a group that
previously didn't have it all you really
had in all the comics was like the sky
fathers basically the leader of the
earthly pantheon of gods and like they
meet up sometimes and do stuff they get
their nails done talk about their
feelings they're modern men but beyond
that like we don't really have any
organization or structure in terms of
how they work i love the idea of the of
omnipotent city throwing it in there and
then basically saying this is where all
the gods meet i love that idea right
where the gods all dwell and they all
have their own location and that kind of
thing i love that whole concept right so
following that of course we get these
various gods over the course of the
movie some of whom gore fought some of
whom we simply just saw but the god of
dumplings is basically a reference to
that like kawaii anime aesthetic which
is really interesting to see i hope i'm
pronouncing that right very terrible
when it comes to pronouncing like
japanese names or words different things
like that but then you also had like the
game of thrones god who was basically
made of scissors
right now one of the cool things that
happened in omnipotent city and this is
a really cool moment that i'm sure
pissed off all the people that hate jane
foster but you know what the sun rose
and the day went on and you're okay
so relax bro
take a chill pill so basically you know
jane foster is given the title of thor
by thor in omnipotent city now it didn't
exactly happen that way in the comics
but it's still the concept being carried
over from the comics that what you had
was in a lot of ways thor like when jane
foster officially like took the took
mjolnir and then became thor what you
had was a subsection of the comic book
fandom who was like no like we want thor
to reject her because we reject her we
don't want her to be thor so we don't
want thor to want her to be thor and
jason aaron was like tough so basically
he had this moment in the comic where
literally odin's son is like you can be
thor and it pissed off all the people
that hated jane foster it was kind of
funny honestly i i i i don't normally do
this but
i was just basking in their tears like i
was loving their tears it was just like
yes you know your tears taste delicious
it was it was i i absolutely loved it
because i loved the character and i
loved to see that that basically marvel
was willing to take a risk with changing
the entire landscape of thor even if
only temporarily but after a while you
just get bored of reading the same thing
all the time and so the way i always
kind of saw it was you had fans who were
like yeah this is cool i want to see
where this goes and then you had other
fans who wanted to just drag things down
to like boredom and the way they had
always been because they didn't want to
leave their comfort zone so i i loved i
loved the fact that they they had
changed things up and i loved the
character of jane but beyond that you
got celestials in omnipotent city as
well as having statues of themselves in
the hall of eternity now this led to a
lot of people asking the question
why did we see
any of the celestials in omnipotent city
and unless i missed something this was
not a question that was readily answered
but i think the answer to that question
is because of null and it's because of
gore right they're like gore and null
are linked in that way and in fact we'll
talk about that more once you get to
literally like that whole black and
white realm but one of the things to
know is that when it came to know the
symbiote god the celestials were well
aware of him they were and in fact the
reason why the celestials knew of of
null is because they fought in the
distant past in the early days of the
universe that when the celestials quote
unquote moved in and started like
creating life and so on it pissed off
null because he was basically in this
realm of just darkness right he loved he
loved living in a realm of darkness
right
he sat around all day smoking cigarettes
listened to the cure i don't know but
like he was he was just emo well he's
just misunderstood by the world and here
comes the celestials with happiness and
they pissed him off but in all reality
like they were creating life and they
were creating light in a world or in a
space that was all darkness and so what
this did is it led to null going to war
against the celestials he successfully
killed one and then when that happened
the celestials banished him back to his
own dimension and then ultimately he
ended up escaping again which led to him
going across the cosmos killing all the
gods he could find because his argument
was if i cannot readily defeat the
celestials head on i'll destroy
everything they're building and then
when there's nothing left then i'll take
them on because literally i will kill
all the gods and absorb their energy
into myself so basically the actions of
gore before gore it's one of the reasons
why in the comics when gore got the
necro sword that null stood hands off
and just let gore continue on his
journey literally they cover that in
king and black you know because it's the
question we had why didn't all step in
and take his sword back from gore when
gore used it and the answer of null is
he was basically completing my my whole
quest without me so why would i just why
would i kill this spec of an alien on
some world somewhere and take my sword
back because let's be honest with
ourselves null could have absolutely
crushed gore with the greatest of ease
it would not it would not have been a
contest at all but that's why the
celestials i think in this particular
scene they're aware of null right at
some previous point in time in the
universe's history they fought and like
they know who null is they like we know
that like marvel and sony are working on
a joint project with null the symbiote
god so it makes perfect sense that we
would basically see the celestials on
alert and just be like okay so like
somebody's got to do something about
gore because if they don't he's going to
either become the next null or he's
gonna wake up null and if he wakes up
nola then we're all screwed because if
you thought thanos was bad he's the
least of our concerns so having said
that the character of zeus was
interesting i didn't necessarily have a
problem with zeus and in fact i i love
the way he was depicted because i felt
like he was a great juxtaposition to the
way that thor used to be right if you
guys notice i don't know how many of you
guys notice that but he was a reflection
of thor's past right arrogant full of
hubris his former idol all that kind of
stuff like it was one of those things
where in a lot of ways thor had looked
up to zeus but zeus was reminiscent of
the person thor used to be and it's not
who he is anymore and so in a lot of
ways i mean zeus is cool obviously
there's a big post-credit moment that
focuses with him or at least that offers
an expansion with the character of zeus
and the rest of the olympian mythos but
what's what what matters there is i felt
like zeus was in a lot of ways thrown in
here to give us an illustration of how
how much different thor is now than he
used to be how much he's changed now i
think that's readily obvious to us but i
don't think he was readily obvious to
thor and so that i think is one of the
coolest moments that came from from the
whole film now of course thor's back
tattoo is indeed loki horns so that's
awesome
[Laughter]
but the necro sword also has his own
realm called the shadow well right now
at this point this is where i think
things got really really cool because in
its own realm the shadow realm i think
that is the realm of of no the symbiote
god right that's where like the living
abyss and all that kind of stuff comes
from that's literally him like that's
where the sword was created or where the
sword has existed that's where it
originated so on and so forth it all
comes from null at the same time right
the monochrome world about the black and
white world as i like to refer to it as
right that this is basically a place
where the only things with color are the
things that radiate with godly powers
right like the glow of weapons and more
importantly here i don't know how many
of you guys noticed more importantly
here gore's eyes and what i think this
means is not that gore is a god but the
gore is channeling the power of a god
which is the necro sword the sword of
null the symbiote god right and i think
that is because gore is basically not i
wouldn't say absorbing the power of null
but channeling the power of no the power
of a being greater than himself that's
what i think is going on and there if
there's anything in this movie that i
think solidifies the existence of noel
the symbiote god i think it's that i
think it's that particular moment here
now this is why i say i think what thor
4 is is in a lot of ways like the empire
strikes back like phase 4 in general is
kind of the empire strikes back of the
mcu i mean obviously thor 4 is not like
like i'm not saying like it's as good as
empire strikes back right i mean i'm
sure some star wars fan out there is
going to be like are you saying that
thor 4 is as good as empire strikes back
because bro
that's not true no like that's not what
i'm saying what i am saying here is that
empire strikes back was the movie that
established and built the the star wars
universe as it existed at the time it
was an informational film and that's
what i think most of what's going on
with phase four in the mcu is
specifically with thor four i think that
thor four i think doctor strange two
loki this is all stuff where they're
world building and i think that's really
what's going on here because what you
get right like as we as we because at
this point of course we're basically
doing this in chronological order of the
film right the hammer visiting jane
foster wanting to be used in reference
to her final time using the hammer that
was in the original comic book run right
it wanted to be used one last time the
jane foster renouncing the name of lady
thor and wanting to be called mighty
thor is a reference to her actual title
in the comics that thor can share his
powers like shazam does and he does it
in this movie which is an interesting
concept but you basically get this godly
world building thing that they
fast-tracked this idea of jane foster
like she's not gonna make it right what
you also got is you got the hall of
eternity that has statues of ereshim the
watcher the living tribunal and what
appear to be several other cosmic
entities and that eternity is a physical
cosmic being in the mcu and is in
another dimension or another plane of
existence i guess now this is why this
is so important right that one what this
shows is that we basically have
awareness of all these cosmic beings who
exist out there how far reaching that
goes we're not entirely sure are there
other places like this that have other
statues of other godly beings probably
not but the thing here is that by
introducing eternity the way that they
did
which is essentially a wishing machine i
would argue that's the dimension of
manifestations that's basically what
that is i don't know if it actually is
but it looks like it is so i think we've
talked about this before here i can't
remember i don't really know but the
important thing is that for those of you
guys who don't know the dimension of
manifestations is a place in marvel
comics it was established in the old
quasar comics back in 1992 i think it
was and the whole idea behind this is
that the cosmic entities as they appear
in the comics that's not their true form
that when they do appear the way they
show up is a result of an m body so
literally they go to the dimension of
manifestations a being called
anthropomorpho gives them an m body and
then they show up in the main universe
because they are in effect concepts
right despite how powerful they are they
just represent ideologies right it's
like having a conversation with the fact
that you're hungry it's not necessarily
something you can do it's more of a
feeling that you have or a concept that
you know exists out there but when the
the cosmic entities end up taking on an
embody that's when you can physically
see them now one of the other cool
things here is that that's seen in the
movie when you saw eternity in what
looked like gold on one side and black
on the other that was a reference to the
amalgamation eternity which is to say
when eternity and infinity merge
together in a singular being it was not
a one for one copy from the comics but
that's basically what it was because
eternity is basically this guy who looks
like a walking talking universe right
you have stars and galaxies inside of
him and all that kind of stuff infinity
is literally just like gold and black
right so it's really like they they very
much look like an amalgamation between
the two but the thing about this is that
we're getting more and more references
to cosmic entities we're getting more
and more references to the living
tribunal and so on and so forth we're
slowly building up to it and i think you
know as i as i kind of look at that i
think it makes the most sense because if
in like doctor strange two they had just
sprung the living tribunal on everybody
people wouldn't have been able to handle
it the average movie goer would not have
really been able to be they would have
been like okay this is kind of weird
right plus when it comes to the
different cosmic entities you literally
have a hierarchy there where you have
like some that are powerful and then
some that are more powerful and some are
the most powerful right like for example
you do have eternity there's a
multiversal eternity there is a
manifestation of the multiverse that
version of eternity right the physical
form of the multiverse now it's one of
those weird things because having a
multiversal eternity doesn't seem to
make sense in the face of the living
tribunal because the living tribunal is
the multiverse given form so how you
square that circle i'm not entirely sure
basically you know i don't i don't know
like
two stories both different sides of the
same coin whatever who cares the thing
about this is there there's a hierarchy
of power there and i think that by
introducing eternity before we actually
see
the living tribunal as an actual being i
think is important i think it's a
significant thing because it shows us
the place these different beings serve
because one of the things to remember is
that eternity was referenced like the
like eternity death oblivion infinity i
think they were referenced in like the
old school guard like the first
guardians of the galaxy film right
remember like that whole artwork behind
the scenes that kind of thing where like
james gunn and them were talking about
like the cosmic entities where the
infinity stones came from and all that
kind of stuff like they referenced those
cosmic entities so like we know that
like they've been toying with this idea
for years they've just been trying to
figure out how it is they're gonna make
it work and it's cool to see that they
chose this form to do it with so i do
love the cosmic entity idea right the
whole thing about eternity now the thing
about this and this is the caveat and
this is what i think has a lot of people
bothered right eternity is basically a
wishing machine and so that also means
that a lot of people who have died in
the mcu can be brought back and in fact
death itself is effectively meaningless
and that basically it's shown that
bringing someone back from the dead can
be as simple as making a visit to
eternity now there are a couple caveats
here for example we saw a person brought
back i don't necessarily i don't think
it was established that eternity could
bring back an infinite number of people
for an extended period of time but
that's the big question that a lot of
people are asking and that's kind of the
big caveat a lot of people are saying
okay so wait a minute you're telling me
that thor's always known about eternity
which is basically a wishing machine
it's a he's a he's a cosmic cube
essentially right that's what cosmic
cubes were in the comics they were
wishing boxes so you're telling me that
here but eternity is a being who's
basically a wishing machine if you
discover it with the key which turns out
to be uh stormbreaker and you can unlock
that and you can get to eternity you can
wish for anything so so people are
asking why didn't thor just wish back
all like half like all the people who
were snapped out by thanos or why didn't
they just wish thanos out of existence
right or why like why didn't they why
didn't they use that right why didn't
they use eternity and what a lot of
people are seeing this as and honestly i
think it's a legitimate beef that i
think that the marvel cinematic universe
is really going to run the problems with
this if they're not careful people are
starting to see it as this ongoing use
of mcguffins that what you have here are
writers and directors who are creating
stories and they don't know how to end
them and so what they're doing is just
quite literally pulling random stuff out
of their ass and then just saying well
what if gore goes to eternity
and just wishes his daughter back and
then not giving any real thought to the
question in the greater scheme of
everything that's happened in the mcu
how is this going to affect it because
now people are kind of people are
literally asking these questions like
why why did they do that before why
didn't thor do that before why did the
avengers go through all that what all
thor had to do was like hey wait a
minute guys everybody relax everybody
chill i know things are pretty bad but
here's the thing so so out in the
dimension of manifestations right
there's this dude that just sits around
all day long doing literally nothing
and and it's really a statue more than
anything else that basically looks like
the universe and because i have storm
breaker now we can just go there and
just wish for everything to be undone
and for everything to go back to the way
it was before we can just wish for that
i mean you guys want to do that right i
feel like they all look around and
captain america would be like uh
yeah man
let's do that because trying to figure
out time travel
and then going back into the past
and taking the infinity stones out of
particular locations and how to make
sure we put them back in the exact
locations and all that stuff kind of
seems a little bit unnecessary if all we
have to do is just go to that guy and
ask him to fix everything right like
it's i i totally understand where people
are coming from and this use of
mcguffins in a lot of ways just kind of
seems to be getting out of hand i
wouldn't say that like taika watiti and
those guys are lazy writers and and lazy
directors but what i am saying is the
use of mcguffins in the mcu
kind of feels like it's getting to that
point and and so i certainly see where a
lot of people are just sort of like this
like something needs to be done about
this now what it also does here though
is it does introduce some interesting
possibilities for example gore's
daughter with her like reflection and
everything could potentially be the
universe's stand-in for captain universe
or possibly even cubic and the reason
why is because when she comes back she's
got that whole godly type look right
like that whole that whole like looking
like like the reflection of the universe
eternity that kind of a thing and so for
a while i've suspected that the marvel
cinematic universe is going to try to
find a way to introduce captain universe
and the nature of captain universe is
that it was a being that was designed to
safeguard the universe from various
threats that exist out there and that
with gore having done everything he's
done and if we look at the marvel
cinematic universe phase 4 and thor 4 as
a world building film how far of of of
outside the realm of possibility do you
think it is that gore's actions woke up
null and that if it's true nola's on his
way here and if that's the case eternity
would be aware of it at the very least i
don't we don't know it's any anything
behind its motivations or anything like
that then it basically turns the
daughter of gore into captain universe
and she just goes forward from there i
don't really think she'd be like a cubic
those of you guys who don't know cubic
was basically a sentient cosmic cube
well there were a couple of them there
was kobach way back in the day then
there's cubic which is the more recent
one and i don't really think that's the
case i don't think we're getting like a
like a like you know the daughter of
thor of gore coming back is what's
effectively a cosmic cube channeling the
energy of the beyond verse right or the
energy of eternity or something along
those lines i think it's more reasonable
she would be a captain universe type
character i think that'd be awesome if
that was the case don't necessarily know
if it is but the other thing about this
is that zeus saying that the gods are a
joke of course is likely a reference to
this film
at least this film series of thor
becoming more successful when they
started leaning into more of the jokey
style but again i i feel like it's kind
of wearing out i think it's kind of
wearing a little thin people like okay
look i mean thor being funny was great
for like a movie or so but like we kind
of want serious throwback but i don't i
don't know if we're going to get that
again you know i'm kind of i'm sort of
split i like the comedy element but i
also kind of miss the serious element
right now here's one of the other cool
things too here is that valhalla is a
real place that actually exists which
makes sense given the nature of the thor
mythos and like omnipotent city and all
those places actually exist but that
basically means that the death of almost
any asgardian god and really any god in
general could be made meaningless and
that marvel will probably use this fact
at least at some point to shake up
things by bringing certain characters
back to life so that's cool i love the
idea of valhalla now what this means is
that likely jane foster will go on there
they may bring her back as some
variation of thor later on i wouldn't be
surprised if valkyrie as she exists in
the mcu will end up becoming jane foster
i mean we know that valkyrie is alive
right like she and sif and them are like
training the kids in asgard and so on
and so forth so jane foster is kind of
adamant the only reason i even go with
this is because again that's what
happened in jane foster in the comics
that once she died and passed on that
she went into valhalla and then became a
valkyrie and so that's really where
she's been ever since in fact she has
her own comic book run called valkyrie
which isn't terrible uh it's kind of
cool actually to be to be honest with
you guys but with that being said guys
uh that's everything we spotted right
let us know all the things that that we
may have missed down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace